Arena once again you come here laughing
and smiling and being super happy this
was a pretty good game but it wasn't
easy because she surprised you early on
with this idea of E4 giving up the pawn
she was piling on the pressure on you
early on yeah well um she did say in her
interview yesterday that she was going
to rethink her match strategy and she
definitely came with something different
today I was really really surprised at
the opening because basically let's put
a few moves on the board
yeah this movie E4 I mean I'm a sicilian
player is black and you think like if
you saw something like you know E4 C5
the head of 396 and you played Knight F6
you got an extra move as black would
white ever go E5 I mean you don't see
that you know so I mean of course at
first I thought I was like is she just
confusing things because I've never I
don't even think I've ever played Knight
F3 before yeah it's quite interesting
that she had this preparation in a line
that um she really couldn't have even
expected for me right
um I think perhaps it was prepped for
some other players yeah I mean my guess
would be would be it was it's prepped
for me you know
um it's interesting choice you know
because the thing is of course it was
very uncomfortable for me to be like
surprised in the opening have her
playing instantly
um and I was quite slow and just trying
to understand the idea I was like well I
haven't made any mistakes so like here
go blacko's sacrificing the pawn how is
this going to work out let's pick it up
yeah yeah
and then you think about where your
night should go I mean should you go to
D C3 or G3 but ultimately yeah I didn't
want to let the pawn get to D4 with
Tempo how did you come up to the
conclusion that you have to give this
check or that you want to give this
check well my first instinct I mean I
guess from a while back I was thinking
of probably 92 but then I was ultimately
like you know I really should be
developing my pieces and I didn't see
you know why not develop that bishop and
I mean it did cause her to think it's
interesting and maybe because it's
supposedly not a good move by the engine
like it gives black already an advantage
does it but you know
it's in
I understood this yes like I understood
there's positions in chess like where
the computer will say oh it's great for
black but the computer's idea of
compensation and initiative is not a
human's exactly and if a human cannot
find these moves it doesn't matter you
know so and that was my feeling was like
oh okay so now she's out of her
preparation you know and there's so many
choices for black right like there's
should you drive the pawn into H3 should
you go A6 yes Bishop D6 which Queen G5 I
mean so many moves right so I mean I
think in in this situation
um you know the computer evaluation at
home does doesn't help blacks and she
went the Stray very quickly after uh
with the move Bishop to D6 castle and
now you're already better yeah here
um I played what was it F3 yeah I mean
D4 Castle's Queen side I guess this is
the critical moment right if we go back
the question is can I get after Castle's
Queen side can I get in the movie E4 and
you know ultimately I just felt like it
was too loose you know and you know
there there is some crazy move H3 I
don't really know what's going on with
h3e5
um okay 95 okay well I'm not surprised
it is pretty crazy pretty crazy crazy
position but even if she goes like
without age three if she goes like uh
Pawn takes pawn queen E7 like even this
I really wasn't very sure about I mean
just because the pawns are hanging in
the center yeah it feels like like
you're using your extra Pawn but
actually you're also creating play for
black on the D file lots of tactics lots
of file diagonals so I mean okay I'm
glad to see that the computer agreed
that I shouldn't go for this because I
was certainly thinking about it was
definitely the right choice in the
position just slowly build up your
attack and I really like the fact that
you let your knight stay on E2 yeah
don't go to C3 because you're probably
going to have to come back after the
move G5 you anticipated this move G5 I
can tell you actually when she played
Bishop C7 I was a bit unhappy like I'd
already kind of seen this idea but I was
like oh now she is gonna force me to
play F4 like the same type positional
move I'm gonna have this bad dark
squared Bishop so I was definitely
concerned
when I saw Bishop C7
um but ultimately okay like you know I
blocked the bishop with F4 yes and I
still have this extra Pawn she cannot
trade the light squared Bishops yet
there's play against her King as well so
it felt okay like uh not a disaster
let's say to have a pawn and F4 I I
think at this point you're already kind
of cruising yeah so she she decided to
play very bravely giving up that well I
don't know who's Brave me and taking it
or her and giving it up but like you
know she gave up this Pawn on uh D5 and
um it just wasn't enough yeah oh no that
wasn't our game Christian excuse me Rook
to G6 at this point yeah yeah
to be a little bit careful here oh there
was some there were a lot of like ways I
could go wrong can I just show you one
of them like I mean her whole trick is
that if I go like a move back two moves
back with a pawn still on a2b2 if I go
D5 right like 95 yes I mean that's a big
trick in the position and you definitely
don't want to fall for that because I
guess you guys maybe looked at things
like that but I mean I actually get
myself mated very sad
um you know D5 was like my main idea but
then there was this big obstacle in
playing it so I had to like completely
um
completely reorient myself and find like
a different plan which I guess was was
pretty decent wait you did it was in
fact the best way forward now you're
facing her again tomorrow with the black
pieces all you need is a draw to get the
title how do you feel about your chances
what are you going to do are you going
to do anything differently yeah yeah I
think um I will just play my game and
play the same way I've been playing all
my games and you know hopefully that's
going to be good enough congratulations
Irena we'll see you tomorrow thank you
our congratulations as well Arena as he
continues her